>>HAPP PL-IN TUDAY.
U TAEDNTO "OUP AT."
M CBIE CHAR.SH ALWS BRIS TH BESE
NYIM OHEHOAS OCO. NET'GR Y.OMFAE
AYGA TKIT
EI -ILOAL CMEIL RECVE A
RISKREEETOR THE AY-I
BETWN TSDAY ANDFRAY.
CK O CHRTMAS DA NODY
ULD VE PDICT TT T
GACYFRANISES THE BOSN CEICS,HE
W.ERE.
YOU KNOW, EACH WEEK ON OUR -- IN
OUR CHUCK VERSUS AMERICA
SEGMENT, WE GO TOE TO TOE WITH
THE TWO-TIME HALL OF FAMER.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF MVPs IN THIS
CONVERSATION.
WE GO HEAD TO ED WHEAD WITH TH
O
TWO-TIME HALL OF FAMER.
CHUCK, CONGRATS.
IN OUR LAST MATCH-UP IN CHUCK
VERSUS AMERICA, WE BOTH TOOK
"L"s.
LET'S LOOK AT THE LATEST
STANDINGS IN OUR CHUCK VERSUS
AMERICA STANDINGS.
WE'RE AT 11-5, AND CHUCK IS
CREEPING UP AT 9-5.
ALL THAT MATTERS IS WE'RE AHEAD
AND YOU'RE STILL GENEROUS WITH
YOUR HANDY DANDY iPAD.
>> CABBIE, ERIN AND PEOPLE THAT
ARE AT HOME THIS --
>> I LOVE THAT THING.
>> THIS IS THE iPAD, THIS IS HOW
YOU GET HOODIES.
A LOT OF VIBES ON THIS iPAD.
HERE WE GO.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
22GODIE SAYING HE HAS NEVER WON
HIS HOODIE.
WE WILL GIVE YOU YOUR HOODIE.
STOP SPAMMING THE HOODIES.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT.
WAIT?
>> J. MOM 8 --
>> GIVE HIM A HOODIE SO HE CAN
STOP SPAMMING THE COMMENTS.
A LOT OF GOOD VIBES.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
WE ARE GOING TO DM YOU.
>> JMOM8 SAYS TATUM WILL CLAP
THE WIZARDS.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
NICK FRETO WITH THE BRADLEY BEAL
GIFT.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THAT'S IT FOR NOW, CABBIE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU ARE DEFINITELY GENEROUS,
BRO.
YOU STARTED OFF THE SHOW WITH 19
HOODIES.
SO TONIGHT WE'RE GOING HEAD TO
HEAD WITH CHARLES BARKLEY IN OUR
FAVORITE CHUCK VERSUS AMERICA.
EARLIER TODAY WE ASKED YOU ON
TWITTER, WHO WILL SCORE MORE
POINTS TODAY IN WASHINGTON
VERSUS BOSTON?
JASOYSON TATUM, MINUS 142, OR
BRADLEY BEAL?
AND AMERICA IS VOTING, BRADLEY
BEAL WITH 70% OF THE VOTE.
GREG, WHO ARE YOU SEEING MORE IN
THE COMMENTS?
BEAL OR TATUM?
>> YOU GUYS, TAKE OVER THE
COMMENTS WITH GIFS.
BRADLEY BEAL, JAYSON TATUM, WHO
DO YOU THINK WILL SCORE MORE
POINTS TODAY?
ERIN, BRADLEY BEAL CAME IN
SECOND FOR THE SCORING TITLE
THIS YEAR FOR A REASON.
HE'S -- HE CAN BALL.
HE'S PLUS MONEY.
HOW TEMPTING IS IT TO TAKE HIM
IN THIS SPOT?
>> VERY TEMPTING.
HE AVERAGED 41 POINTS THE LAST
THREE MEETINGS AGAINST BOSTON.
SHOOTING 46% FROM THE
THREE-POINT LINE.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THEY'RE TAKING A GAMBLE
ON BEAL GIVEN THAT HE'S NOT
FULLY HEALTHY WITH THAT
LINGERING HAMSTRING INJURY, I'M
GOING BRADLEY BEAL ESPECIALLY
WITH PLUS MONEY.
>> WHAT?
HIS HAMSTRING, WE SAW, LIKE,
JAMES HARDEN MISS A MONTH --
>> HE'LL BE FINE.
>> DO YOU KNOW SOMETHING WE
DON'T KNOW?
>> THIS IS A PLAY-IN TOURNAMENT
TIME.
IT'S PLAYOFF TIME.
ALL THE INJURIES HOLD OFF UNTIL
THE END OF THE GAME.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
DO YOU SEE THIS DUDE WINCING?
HE WAS WINCING ON THE SIDELINES
IN THE LAST GAME.
>> CABBIE, THOSE ARE BAD VIBES,
BRO.
RELAX.
>> G. MONEY --
>> THIS IS THE PLAY-IN GAME.
>> REALISTIC VIBES.
I GOT TO QUOTE DRIZZY HERE FROM
HIS SONG, THE IDOLS BECOME YOUR
RIVALS.
MAKE FRIEND WITH MIKE, BUT GOT
TO AI FOR YOUR SURVIVAL.
JAYSON TATUM, BRADLEY BEAL, FIVE
YEARS APART.
BOTH FROM ST. LOUIS.
BOTH WENT TO THE SAME HIGH
SCHOOL.
THEY ARE FRIENDS AND THEY WORK
OUT IN THE OFF SEASON.
IDOLS BECOME YOUR RIVALS.
JAYSON TATUM IS THAT DUDE.
HE'S 6'10" AND CAN SCORE AT ALL
THREE LEVELS, AT THE RIM, AT THE
MIDRANGE, WHICH HE LOVES, AND
THEN BEYOND THE ARC.
WHO IS GOING TO GUARD JAYSON
TATUM TONIGHT, GUYS, ON
WASHINGTON?
HAT
ON THAT HAMSTRING?
6'10", 6'3" B3
'3" BRADLEY B?
I'LL TAKE THAT FULLY HEALTHY
JAYSON TATUM OVER BEAL WITH A
LEFT HAMSTRING INJURY.
G. MONEY, WHO DO YOU LOVE IN
THIS MATCH-UP AND WHO DOES THE
AUDIENCE LOVE?
>> CABBIE, I'LL GET THERE.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
I SEE A LOT.
I MEAN A LOT OF BRADLEY BEAL.
>> REALLY?
>> I HAVE MOTIVE AIDED, YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
BRADLEY FIRED UP.
RIGHT THERE.
FLEX ON HIM.
THERE IT IS.
>> THAT'S THE BRADLEY I NEED
TONIGHT.
A FIRED-UP BRADLEY.
>> MGOBLUE16, ANOTHER BRADLEY
BEAL GIF.
HE'S ACTUALLY SMILING IN THIS
ONE.
SMILING IN THIS ONE.
THERE'S THE GIF RIGHT THERE.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I SAID,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
MONEY.
ONE MORE, JWMONEYA.
HE SAYS BRADLEY BEAL WILL WALK
AWAY WITH MORE THAN 40 POINTS.
>> COME ON?
COME ON.
I WOULD LOVE TO SIDE BET THAT 40
POINTS.
THERE'S NO WAY BRADLEY BEAL IS
SCORING 40 TONIGHT.
GO AHEAD, G. MONEY.
>> ERIN SITTING THERE WITH THE
PLUS MONEY.
THE COMMENTS ARE YELLING -- NOT
YELLING, BUT THEY'RE SAYING
BEAL.
THEY'RE YELLING THROUGH GIFS.
THERE'S LITERALLY A BUNCH OF
BRADLEY BEAL GIFS IN THE
COMMENTS.
I HAVE TO ROCK WITH BRADLEY.
I FEEL LIKE HE'S GOING TO HAVE
TO SHOW UP.
YOU'RE ASKING WHO WILL GUARD
JAYSON TATUM?
>> YEAH.
>> CABBIE, WHO IS GOING TO GUARD
BRADLEY BEAL?
>> MARCUS SMART.
>> COME ON.
>> HE'S ONE OF THE BEST --
>> CABBIE, DO YOU REALLY BELIEVE
MARCUS SMART CAN GUARD BRADLEY
BEAL?
>> YES.
ABSOLUTELY!
>> CABBIE.
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW -- I DON'T
THINK MARCUS SMART BELIEVES HE
CAN.
BRADLEY BEAL, 101?
ISOLATION, MARCUS SMART AND
BRADLEY BEAL, YOU THINK HE CAN
GUARD HIM?
>> BRADLEY BEAL IS ONE OF THE
MOST UNDERRATED AND
UNDERAPPRECIATED BASKETBALL
PLAYERS IN THE ASSOCIATION.
MARCUS SMART IS LEGIT.
JAYLEN BROWN NOT BEING IN THE
GAME HURTS.
IF JAYLEN BROWN WAS PLAYING,
THEN MARCUS COULD FOCUS ALL HIS
ATTENTION ON BRADLEY BEAL.
BUT HE'S GOING TO STEP UP.
HE'S PLAYED IN EASTERN
CONFERENCE FINALS SERIES.
THIS GUY IS BUILT FOR THIS.
GIVE ME MARCUS SMART.
BRADLEY BEAL -- HE MIGHT GET TO
30 POINTS, BUT HE MIGHT HAVE TO
TAKE 30 SHOTS OR 35 SHOTS
TONIGHT TO GET THERE.
>> MARCUS SMART IS A DOG.
HE'S A DOG.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
I'M TAKING BRADLEY.
>> AMERICA, CHECK OUT THE INSIDE
THE NBA PREGAME SHOW ON TNT TO
FIND OUT WHO THE GREAT CHARLES
BARKLEY IS RIDING WITH.
I HAVE A FEELING HE WILL SIDE
WITH AMERICA AND BRADLEY BEAL.
GET ON FANDUEL AND BET THE HEAD
TO HEAD MATCH-UP.
THE QUESTION TODAY IS WILL THERE
BE TWO THREE-POINTS MADE IN THE
FIRST THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME?
LAST WEEK, WE LOCKED IN A THREE
BY TWO IN MIAMI VERSUS BOSTON.
JUST LIKE THAT, IT HIT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> REMEMBER HOW WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT MARCUS SMART IN THE
CORNER?
THAT'S MY GUY.
MONEY.
HE HAD A COUPLE OF
THREE-POINTERS IN THAT GAME.
EV
EVAN FORNIER, HE HAD FOUR IN
THAT GAME.
BOTH TEAMS COMBINED FOR 50% FROM
DOWNTOWN.
IT WAS FIREWORKS.
>> YEAHCRAZY.
>> G. MONEY, WHICH ONES DO YOU
WANT TO LOCK IN TONIGHT FOR THE
THREE BY TWO?
THE PACERS AND THE HORNETS OR
THE WIZARDS AND CELTICS?
>> CABBIE, LET ME ASK THE
PEOPLE.
WHICH THREE BY TWO DO YOU THINK
WE SHOULD ROCK WITH?
CHARLOTTE/INDIANA OR
WASHINGTON/BOSTON?
YOU LET ME KNOW.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
ERIN, INDIANA AND WASHINGTON
SCORE A LOT OF POINTS.
THEY'RE TOP SIX IN SCORING.
SHOOTERS ALL AROUND.
WHICH GAME ARE YOU LEANING
TOWARDS?
CHARL
CHARLOTTE,/INDIANA OR
WASHINGTON/BOSTON?
>> I'M GOING WITH
WASHINGTON/BOSTON.
I THINK THE BEST CHANCE FOR YOUR
THREE BY TWO HERE, WIZARDS
VERSUS THE CELTICS.
NO DOUBT.
>> I DISAGREED WITH YOU LAST
TIME, BUT I'M WITH YOU ON THIS
ONE.
THE CELTICS HAVE LIMPED INTO THE
PLAY-IN TOURNAMENT LOSING SIX OF
THE LAST EIGHT GAMES.
SO THERE'S SOME URGENCY OVER
THERE WITH BOSTON.
IF YOU SUBSCRIBE TO THE NEXT MAN
UP THEORY BECAUSE JAYLEN BROWN
IS OUT WITH SEASON-ENDING WRIST
SURGERY, YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
EVAN FORNIER AND KEMBA WALKER AS
THE TWO GUYS WHO GET IT STARTED
WITH THE CELTICS.
THOSE ARE THE DUDES I'M LOOKING
AT.
LET'S LOCK IN WIZARDS/CELTICS
TONIGHT.
WHERE DOES YOUR WINNER'S ONLY
ARMY WANT TO SPRINKLE?
>> CABBIE, I'M IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
HOODIES.
I SEE A LOT -- I SEE A WHOLE
BUNCH OF STUFF.
I GOT BEN THE MVP, HE'S ROCKING
WITH BOSTON.
BOSTON AND WASHINGTON.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
TAYLOR PAYNE IS WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
JESSE BOLANOS, WASHINGTON VERSUS
BOSTON, THEY HAVE MORE FIRE
POWER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THERE'S A LOT OF LOVE FOR
WASHINGTON AND BOSTON.
>> WHICH GAME ARE YOU LOCKING
IN?
>> THERE'S ANOTHER GAME BEING
PLAYED TODAY.
CHARLOTTE VERSUS INDIANA.
THE ODDS ARE PLUS 100 FOR A
REASON I FEEL LIKE.
LET'S SHOW SOME LOVE TO THIS
GAME, TOO.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK, CABBIE AND
ERIN.
I THINK BOTH THREE BY TWOS WILL
HIT.
I'M GOING TO PUT THOSE VIBES
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE.
I WANT TO SHOW SOME LOVE TO
CHARLOTTE AND INDIANA.
THEY HAVE SHOOTERS ALL AROUND.
TERRY LaMELO ON ONE TEAM?
>> DE'VANTE GRAHAM.
>> I KNOW THEY GOT THE NEWS WITH
LeVERT NOT PLAYING.
BUT THEY SCORE POINTS.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT ALREADY IN
THE SHOW.
SHOW SOME LOVE TO
CHARLOTTE/INDIANA, TAKE THAT
MONEY AND PUT IT ON
WASHINGTON/BOSTON AND HAVE
YOURSELF A DAY.
>> I'M GLAD YOU PICKED THAT.
WE NEEDED SOME LOVE ON THAT
FIRST GAME.
WE DID
>> ALL RIGHT.
GOOD LUCK, G. MONEY.
ARE YOU DOING AN INSTAGRAM LIVE
TONIGHT?
>> YEAH.
WE'LL BE LIVE TONIGHT RIDING THE
THREE BY TWO.
WE HAVE TO PICK WHICH ONE.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHICH ONE
WE'RE RIDING WITH.
THAT'S THE ONE WE'LL TAKE TO
INSTAGRAM LATER ON.
>> TAP INTO THE B/R IG BETTING
ACCOUNT FOR THAT.
BRING YOUR GOOD VIBES ONLY.
MAKE SURE TO TAP IN WITH B/R
BETTING SOCIAL TO GET THE LINK
TO THE THREE BY TWO FOR EITHER
PACERS AND HORNETS OR WIZARDS
AND CELTICS.
THERE'S NO OFFICIAL WORD ON
WHETHER LeBRON JAMES IS A FAN OF
THE SHOW "THE QUEENS GAMBIT" OR
THE MOVIE "FRESH" IS ONE OF HIS
FAVORITE MOVIES WITH SAM
JACKSON.
WE KNOW LeBRON JAMES HAS BEEN
PLAYING 4D CHESS FOR A LONG
TIME.
EVERY TIME HE PUBLICLY PRAISES
HIS RIVAL, STEPH CURRY BY
CALLING HIM THE MVP THIS YEAR OR
AT THE ALL-STAR WEEKEND THROWING
UP VARIOUS HASHTAGS ON TWITTER,
LIKE #GREATESTSHOOTEROFALLTIME
OR #CHANGEDHOWTHE GAGAMEISPLAYE
DO YOU THINK HE'S GENUINE OR
THIS IS GAMESMANSHIP FROM LeBRON
OR IS HE RECRUITING WITHOUT
RECRUIT?
>> YOU CAN NEVER DENY THAT HE
CAN RECRUIT PLAYERS.
HE IS LeBRON JAMES.
I ALSO THINK -- I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S GENUINE, I THINK LeBRON
LOVES TO STIR UP THE DRAMA AND
GET PEOPLE TALKING.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HIM ON THE
SHOW, THAT'S WHAT LeBRON JAMES
WANTS.
HE LOVES THAT.
I'M NOT SURE.
BUT, YEAH.
WE CANLeBRON JAMES IS
WATCHING THE SHOW.
>> HE'S A HUGE FAN OF B/R
BETTING, HE WON'T REVEAL WHAT
GAMES HE'S SPRINKLING ON.
THE AUDIENCE WILL LET US KNOW
WHERE TO GET IN ON THE ACTION.
WHO'S A LOCK TO HIT THEIR PLAYER
TOTALS FOR TOMORROW'S GAME,
GOLDEN STATE INSIDE THE STAPLES
CENTER.
ARE THEY RIDING WITH STEPH CURRY
OR LeBRON JAMES?
>> LET ME ASK THEM.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
WHO IS HITTING THE OVER
TOMORROW?
STEPH CURRY OR LeBRON JAMES.
ERIN, WHO DO YOU THINK IS
HITTING THE POINT TOTAL
TOMORROW?
>> BOTH OF THESE ARE SO HIGH.
STEPH AND LeBRON PLAYED EACH
OTHER 22 TIMES, ALL HAVE BEEN IN
THE NBA FINALS, WHICH IS A CRAZY
STAT TO THINK ABOUT.
IF I HAD TO PICK BETWEEN THESE
TWO, I WOULD HAVE TO GO STEPH
CURRY.
I KNOW IT'S SO HIGH.
HE IS THE FIRST PLAYER 33 YEARS
OR OLDER TO LEAD THE LEAGUE IN
SCORING SINCE MICHAEL JORDAN.
AVERAGING 32 POINTS.
A SINGLE ELIMINATION STEP, IF
I'M GOING TO PICK SOMEBODY TO GO
OVER, I'D PICK HIM.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU THAT STEPH
CURRY IS AT THE HEIGHT OF HIS
POWERS AND HE WON HIS SECOND NBA
SCORING TITLE, BUT LAKERS HEAD
COACH FRANK VOGEL IS A TACTICIAN
AND THE LAKERS HAVE A GREAT
DEFENSE EVEN THOUGH LeBRON JAMES
AND ANTHONY DAVIS MISSED A TON
OF TIME.
THEY'LL BE DOUBLE TEAMING HIM,
TRYING TO CONTAIN STEPH CURRY.
36 1/2 POINTS IS A VERY HIGH
TOTAL.
SO I'M STAYING AWAY FROM THAT,
EVEN THOUGH STEPH CURRY HAS THE
HOT HAND.
SO IF ANYTHING, I'LL COME UNDER
THE TOTAL.
I'LL SIDE WITH THE PLAYMAKING
FACILITATOR, LeBRON JAMES.
THIS IS A BIG MOMENT.
HIS LEGACY IS AT STAKE.
BRON WILL SHOW UP.
HE ALWAYS DOES.
GIVE ME THE OVER 26 1/2 POINTS.
AND I DON'T THINK STEPH CURRY IS
GOING TO GET TO 27 POINTS.
G. MONEY, ARE YOU RIDING WITH
L.A. OR THE BAY?
>> THE BAY, CLEAR.
>> 37 POINTS IN STAPLES?
THAT'S A LOT.
>> I THOUGHT WE HAD TO PICK
WHICH ONE WE WOULD HIT OVER?
>> YEAH.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS
THEN I'LL GIVE YOU MY TAKE.
I HAVE EDDIE ON THE GO ROCKING
WITH YOU, CABBIE, LeBRON JAMES.
LeBRON CELEBRATING HIS
CHAMPIONSHIP RIGHT THERE.
>> NICE.
ROCKING WITH SHIMMY STEPH.
JOYAM ROCKING WITH SHIMMY STEPH.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
CAB
CABBIE, I SEE A LOT OF STEPH.
I SEE A LOT OF BRON WILL SHOW
UP.
BUT I'M SEEING A LOT OF STEPH.
>> WHICH FORMER MVP ARE YOU
GOING WITH?
CAN YOU --
>> FOR ONCE IN YOUR LIFE, CAN
YOU BE OBJECTIVE IN A SELECTION?
IS IT ALWAYS PURELY --
>> I'M ALWAYS OBJECTIVE.
>> WHAT?
>> THE OPPOSITE OF OBJECTIVE.
>> I USE A LOT OF LOGIC.
I USE A LOT OF LOGIC.
IN THIS CASE, IN THIS CASE,
STEPH CURRY IS THE ALPHA ON THIS
WARRIORS TEAM.
>> I WOULD SAY DRAYMOND IS THE
ALPHA.
>> ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
AS FAR AS IN SCORING, AS FAR AS
IN LEADING THIS TEAM ON THE
OFFENSE?
STEPH CURRY IS THE ALPHA ON THIS
TEAM.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, THE
WARRIORS NEED STEPH CURRY TO
PERFORM TOMORROW.
THEY NEED HIM TO PERFORM.
WHETHER THEY WIN OR NOT, WE
DON'T KNOW.
WILL STEPH CURRY PERFORM?
YES.
I DO THINK STEPH CURRY WILL
PERFORM.
LeBRON, HE RODE HIS ANKLE IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER OF THE LAST GAME.
DO YOU THINK I THINK HE'S GOING
TO GIVE ME 27 ON A BROKE ANKLE?
NO.
I WILL TAKE A HEALTHY STEPH
CURRY, 36, GIVE IT TO ME.
TAKE IT TO THE BANK.
HOPEFULLY THE WARRIORS WIN AND
WE'LL SEE.
I'M TAKING STEPH CURRY TO SHOW
UP.
>> BRON PROBABLY HAS A
HYPERBARIC CHAMBER AT HIS HOUSE
OR HE'LL DIP HIS FOOT IN A BLOCK
OF ICE.
HE'LL BE READY.
BRON IS ALWAYS READY.
HOW COULD YOU EVER TRY TO PLAY
ME, KILL THEM ON A SONG, WALK
ABOUT THE BOOTH AND DO THE
WESTBROOK ROCK A BABY.
I'M SORRY, JERMAINE, I BUTCHERED
YOUR LINE.
HE DROPPED SOME NEW HEAT THIS
WEEK.
MAYBE THE TRACK AMARE WILL
INSPIRE RUSSELL WESTBROOK
TONIGHT.
MAYBE IT WILL INSPIRE GREG IVORY
TO HIT A FIVE-LEG SAME-GAME
PARLAY.
G. MONEY, LET'S HOPE THAT YOU DO
BETTER THAN YOU DID TWO WEEKS
AGO WHEN YOU WENT 0 FOR 5.
CAN WE LOOK AT LAST WEEK'S
TICKET?
YOU WENT 2 FOR 5.
>> SOMEWHAT BETTER.
>> BATTING ZERO TO .400.
NK
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
WE'RE GETTING BETTER.
LIKE IN BASEBALL, WHEN YOU HAVE
A PITCHER OUT THERE THAT IS
STRUGGLING, YOU KNOW, USUALLY
THE MANAGER, HE CALLS THE
BULLPEN, HE GETS SOMEONE WARMED
UP.
HE GOES OUT THERE AND MAKES THE
MOVE.
LAST WEEK I CALLED ON MAD
DODGER.
MAD DODGER, MAD RESPECT TO HIM.
WE WENT 2 FOR 5.
THAT'S OKAY.
I'M ON MY WAY TO THE MOUND RIGHT
NOW.
I WENT LIKE THIS.
SO I'M CALLING -- I WENT TO THE
BULLPEN, YOU CAN SEE THAT.
CALLED TO THE BULLPEN, I TAPPED
IN WITH PAULEY O.
WE CAME UP WITH THIS PARLAY
FIVE.
SAME GAME PARLAY FOR THE
WASHINGTON WIZARDS/BOSTON
CELTICS GAME.
WE'RE GOING TO START IT OFF LIKE
THIS.
WE'LL START IT OFF LIKE THIS.
WASHINGTON WIZARDS PLUS 2 1/2.
>> LOVE THAT.
>> I THINK THEY WIN OUTRIGHT.
>> ME, TOO.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN BALLING.
THEY HAVE BEEN BALLING DOWN THE
STRETCH.
BOSTON, YOU KNOW, THEY DON'T
HAVE THEIR BEST PLAYERS.
WE'LL SEE.
ONE OF THEIR BEST PLAYERS.
SO WE'LL SEE.
I LIKE THE 2 1/2.
GOING TO TAKE THE OVER HERE.
WASHINGTON, I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY TIMES I SAID IT ON THE
SHOW.
I DON'T THINK THEY KNOW WHAT
DEFENSE IS.
A LOT OF THEIR GAMES ARE HIGH
SCORING.
TOP SIX -- THEY'RE TOP SIX IN
THE LEAGUE IN SCORING
THEMSELVES.
SO I LIKE THE OVER.
TAKE IT TO THE BANK.
WE'LL GO OVER TO RUSS.
GO GET 13 1/2.
GIVE ME 14 ASSISTS, RUSS.
THIS ISIS PLAYOFF BASKETBALL.
TRIPLE-DOUBLE KING.
GET ME 14.
GO GET ME 14 AND ABOVE.
THIS IS PLAYOFF BASKETBALL.
IT'S TIME.
IT IS TIME, BRODY.
MOVING ON.
JAYSON TATUM.
JAYSON TATUM, CABBIE.
>> YOU TOOK THE UNDER?
>> I LIKE THE UNDER ON THIS,
TOO.
>> WHAT?
>> YOU SAID HIGH TOTAL.
WHAT DO YOU --
>> ON WESTBROOK, 14 ASSISTS.
WESTBROOK, HE'S DONE IT.
WHEN HE'S WEARING HIS BIG BOY
PANTS.
>> THESE ARE STEPH CURRY
NUMBERS.
32 1/2?
HE'S NOT 30.
JA
>> JAYSON TATUM THREE WEEKS AGO
DROPPED 60 ON HIS HOME COURT
AGAINST THE SPURS.
>> AGAINST THE SPURS.
IT WASN'T PLAYOFF BASKETBALL.
IT'S NOT --
>> THEY CAME BACK FROM 32 POINTS
DOWN.
IT WAS DEFINITELY LIKE PLAYOFF
BASKETBALL.
BRO, I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU'RE
DISRESPECTING JAYSON TATUM.
MY GUY IS 23, 6'10" AND --
>> SO FAR I LIKE THESE.
HOW MANY DO YOU THINK TATUM WILL
SCORE THEN?
>> YEAH, CABBIE.
YEAH, CABBIE.
HOW MANY DO YOU THINK HE'LL
SCORE?
>> 34, 37 TONIGHT.
30 PLUS FOR SURE.
>> BET IT.
>> 30 PLUS FOR SURE.
34 TO 37 IS WHAT I PREDICT.
>> BET IT.
>> I'LL BET THE MONEY.
>> SHOULD HAVE BEEN AN
ODDSMAKER.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>>> LET ME WRAP THIS UP.
HERE WE GO.
I WILL GO WITH THE FIRST HALF
OVER.
I THINK THE FULL GAME OVER WILL
HIT.
SO I THINK IT'S JUST GOING TO BE
AN OVER SHOW.
THE FIRST HALF OVER WILL HIT.
MAYBE THE FIRST QUARTER OVER
WILL HIT.
FULL GAME OVER WILL HIT.
HONESTLY I DO NOT THINK THEY
KNOW WHAT DEFENSE IS.
GIVE ME THE POINTS.
>> THE LAST TWO LEGS --
REMEMBER, BEAL IS NOT 100%.
HE HAD, LIKE, I THINK LIKE 5 FOR
27 IN HIS LAST GAME.
HOBBLING AROUND.
>> NEITHER IS LeBRON JAMES, BUT
YOU MADE THE ARGUMENT THAT IT'S
FINE BECAUSE IT'S THE PLAYOFFS.
>> IT'S BRON, THOUGH.
>> ERIN IS THROWING FACTS.
SHE'S THROWING FACTS RIGHT AT
YOU, CABBIE.
I'M SO HAPPY SHE'S HERE.
IT WAS KELLY AND CABBIE AGAINST
GREG.
NOW I'M SENSING SOME DIVIDE.
>> LISTEN, THOSE -- THOSE LAST
TWO LEGS ARE PROBLEMATIC.
LET'S SEE THE TICKET THIS WEEK.
WHAT ARE WE DEALING WITH ON A
$100 BET?
OR ON A $50 BET.
WE GOT 7 -- I GUESS IT'S 14/1 IF
WE PAY OUT ABOUT 700.
OKAY.
THAT'S DECENT.
WHAT DOES THE AUDIENCE THINK OF
THIS TICKET?
>> SHOUT OUT TO PAULEY O.
>> WHAT DOES THE AUDIENCE THINK
OF THE TICKET?
ARE YOU GIVING AWAY MORE HOODIES
BEFORE WE GET OUT OF HERE?
>> NICK SAYS COME ON, CABBIE,
VIBE WITH US.
COME ON, CABBIE, YOU HAVE TO
I HAVE RAIDER 909, VIBING WITH
YOU.
TATUM OVER 32 1/2.
THE FINISHING WITH 38 TO 40
POINTS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU RAIDER 909.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
OVER FOR THE FIRST HALF, NOT
RONALD OKUNA JR., SHOUT OUT TO
YOU.
YOU HAVE A HOODIE.
QUESAR 310 SAYS WIZARDS WEAK
DEFENSE, HE'S SCORING.
TATUM WILL GO OFF.
BUT NOTHING MUCH ELSE.
SO I THINK HE THINKS TATUM WILL
GO OVER ON THE PLAY TOTAL, BUT
DOESN'T THINK THEY'LL WIN THE
GAME.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
CABBIE, I'M DONE.
>> ERIN, DO YOU LIKE G. MONEY'S
TICKET DO YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH ANY OF THE LEGS?
>> I LIKE IT.
THE ONLY PROBLEM THAT WE COULD
RUN INTO IS IF FOR SOME REASON
THIS GAME HITS UNDER, THEN YOU
LOSE THE TWO LEGS THERE BECAUSE
YOU TOOK THE FIRST HALF OVER AND
THEN THE END OF THE GAME AS
WELL.
HONESTLY, THE WIZARDS CONSTANTLY
HIT OVER.
I'M NOT TOO CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
YOU SEEM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
JAYSON TATUM THING.
IS THAT THE ONLY LEG YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT?
>> I'M WORRIED ABOUT THAT FOR
SURE.
FIRST HALF OVER.
IF THEY COME OUT NOT WITH THE
URGENCY THEY NEED AND IT'S
SLOPPY, I THINK YOU'LL BE
SWEATING THAT FIRST HALF.
>> YOU WOULD HOPE THERE WOULD BE
URGENCY.
>> YES.
AND DEFINITELY SWEATING THE
JAYSON TATUM.
>> DO YOU EVEN BET FIRST HALVES?
>> SOMETIMES.
I'M BETTING ON THE CELTICS.
BOOK THAT.
OKAY.
>> AND JAYSON TATUM, A
DOUBLE-DOUBLE.
THAT'S FOR ANOTHER STREAM.
LISTEN, THANK YOU FOR TAPPING
INTO THE "GROUP CHAT" PRESENTED
BY FANDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
SOME PEOPLE BET EMOTIONALLY AND
WILL LIVE WITH HEARTBREAK FOR
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES.
AKA GREG IVORY.
NEXT WEEK WE'RE BACK ON
THURSDAY.
MAKE SURE TO TAP IN WITH US.
MARK YOUR CALENDARS.
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN AND GREG
IVORY, I'M CABBIE RICHARDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US ON A TUESDAY.
WE'RE LEAVING THE "GROUP CHAT."
PEACE.
♪